oh darn it
all right partner all right all right
partner this is the first
first all right partner of the day
that's when you got rob gronkowski
on the other end you know it already
caught it you know we got to get we got
to get rob gronkowski in this
i have a question a little bit oh yeah
actually done even though i live there
already try
oh it's good speed oh turn turn
that's a nice pot very nice now you
leave phil with that almost automatic
yes
i think he did no clue dude
second shot for brady
that's all right fairway and i got the
backstop so yeah
sorry bart no worries it's a little
thick the game is and your misses are
yeah pretty good
to win the hole
and down it goes
why won't you just give me that and just
save a little time on the back end
you don't miss those no great pot
partner
good job boys
yeah that's a nice shot
okay well very well done bye good shot
we have a putt for par
tom brady
stop push it wind push it push it come
on left come on
ah still a good shot yeah let's get
short
i guess it wasn't just short not bad at
all
all right tom brady for birdie here
oh come on come back back you try i'm
ready for that huh i didn't see i had to
fly on my
leg you want to see this you okay with
that yeah
i'm fine with that good you're good got
the driver
[Applause]
oh dude here we go got a good shape
[Applause]
with a gallery
enjoyed that
[Applause]
pretty good get off that hill
it's all right i might have given you a
backlog delay on that for the language
brady
so
a little bit uh i'm surprised bryson's
didn't get down to the hole
i thought he hit it perfect can't
believe that ball stopped right there
yeah
nice
wow great touch easy it's pretty good
it's good really good bro
still a good pot
brady's got a seven iron one club
challenge
nice shot hmm all right get to the
fairway
good swing that's the one he needed on
the last hole oh no it's there
hello man
there's brady
oh man i try that's good
i like the emotion there that's good
good try partner
couldn't see it yours looked like it
bounced right back in the fairway and
passed that guy in the camera
i think it is yeah
difference in those two bounces coming
off that slope for rogers
in the rough brady right in the middle
of fairway they're down three
with four to play do they have a
comeback in them we're at the 15th hole
stay up stay up stay up
oh man that's good guys good pot good
pot dude
good pot my man